please welcome the one and only joseph
gordon levitt
[Applause]
thank you for having me oh my gosh i'm
so excited me too
i am just i
i
i've loved you my whole life that's how
i feel about you drew honestly it's
really true
thank you
i i it's
not easy i remember saying to my
daughters
they were in the back of the car and we
were talking about someone
and i said you know it's hard to grow up
at all let alone in front of everybody
i had done uh tv movies feature films
commercials before et i'd already been
at it for years and you had two before
third round that's true yeah because i
started working when i was six and i
started third rock from the sun when i
was 13. so how did you
learn boundaries because even as a
parent now when my kids were young and
people would be like well you know
boundaries and i was like
no i didn't have any as a kid i wasn't
in a job that did my parents didn't
my wife and i talk about boundaries a
lot that it's it's they're it's
important to give lots of
play room but it's also important that
the boundaries don't move we read this
study it was a really interesting thing
where they they conducted the study with
rats right and uh they they put a a wall
around them
and and then they um
had another group of rats that didn't
have a wall
and the rats that didn't have a wall
bunched closer together and were kind of
much more nervous and didn't play as
adventurously as the rats who had
a wall
because if you know where the wall is if
you know where the boundary is then
you're free to play within those
boundaries if you don't know where the
boundary is then
you're kind of uncertain the whole time
and you don't know
you don't know where the boundary is the
walls do make you feel safer
and i love that analogy will forever
live with me thank you oh good i'm so
happy
i'm happy
well
there is a story about a casting
director oh yeah and i was wondering if
you'd tell it because it seems like it
was a moment that
may have changed your life yeah it
really did this is a story about the
very first audition i ever went on it
was um
for a red lobster commercial
and um and i had to go in and sing and i
got in there and froze
couldn't do it
and once i had kind of finished
stumbling my way through the song the
casting director looked me right in the
eye and said that was great
thank you
and
what i love about this is that he didn't
have to do that and it would have
destroyed me at six years old and i
probably never would have gone on
another audition again because i would
have been traumatized and i wouldn't
have become an actor but because this
guy took an extra couple minutes in his
day to be kind
now i get to be here and doing this and
talking to you
i just i don't know him
i don't know who it was
but i'm so grateful to that guy
where is he i don't know help me find
him i would love that if you're that man
if you are the man
who set the example of how we should all
treat each other and change the
trajectory of joseph gordon's
life making all of our lives better
please find us
the drewberrymore show.com joseph gordon
love it red lobster commercial eons ago
you changed his life and you changed all
of our life for it thank you for sharing
that story may we all remember it
because how we treat each other has the
most tremendous effects on the rest of
our lives which leads me directly to
asking you about steven spielberg and
working with him yeah may i ask what
your experience working with him was
like and you were about to go into
directing yourself that was the thing
yeah i was about to direct my first
feature film don john when we shot
lincoln when i got to work with him and
so obviously i have the opportunity to
observe one of the greats yeah i was
just watching him like a hawk the whole
time and
one of the things that i noticed was he
didn't have a shot list and at one point
i actually worked up the courage to say
like
hey steven do you
do you have a shot list
and he was like well no here let me show
you i like to just watch what you guys
do first and then i figure it out i'm
like
you just figure it out these
spielbergian cinematic shots that you
make he hasn't listed them he hasn't
storyboarded them he can just he can
just kind of whip them up he watches
what the actors do and he's like the
camera should go
here
he can just see it now um switching
gears a little bit super pumped
the battle for uber i am
five episodes in oh nice i'm so into it
oh good oh i don't like it
tell me
how you play someone so insatiable
it's so good
travis kalanick who who co-founded uber
he he
he made the fastest growing startup in
history there's something really
admirable about that he changed the
world
yeah the question is what was the cost
and who had to pay that cost
because a lot of the folks especially
the drivers who are working
with uber or for uber the employees of
uber
they really kind of got a bad deal and
why can't we reward companies
who do great things but don't have to
step on people even if they're a little
bit less successful
[Music]
you